I'm the only one
Hitomi-chan, let's
come to
Kisoji Let's make a name, panda Ah, I
'm
cool,
I'm a good girl, put more effort into it Why me?  You shouldn't eat something like this
oh oh oh oh
hey
hiroe Don't waste your food, you can't
do it because I'm
here Hiroya
me
[music
] I don't even have the slightest bit of love for Okutsu Handa.
It's been
302 years, so it's not like I'm happy
Hey, it's amazing 5 c Exclusive road
go The wind is a sofa What is it?
[Music]
[Applause]
me
me  The one I made today will probably be tastier
2 losses, and
I won't accept it If I do that, I'm sure that guy will treat me badly before My
first love is terrible every day Even if
it lasts, I haven't decided yet
I'm ready 5  Muchin is on the mountain road, no
,
women don't have pandas on their side
[music]